>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> John Cole: Well good
afternoon and welcome
to the Library of Congress.
I'm John Cole.
I'm the director of the Center for
the Book in the Library of Congress,
which promotes books, reading,
literacy, and libraries on behalf
of the Library of Congress.
We were created almost 40 years
ago by the Librarian of Congress,
Daniel Boorstin, when
he was a librarian.
And we operate primarily here
at the library through events
such as this one, which are
noontime events by new books,
by people who have a
special association
with the Library of Congress.
But we also operate
nationally through a system
of affiliated state centers.
Each state has an affiliation that
works with us to promote books,
reading, and literacy in their
states and they also kind
of do their own thing
in their state.
They are each either with a state
library or a humanities council,
and they develop their own programs
but we provide not only a link
with the Library of Congress
but occasional support.
A second way we operate
nationally is through reading
and literacy promotion partners.
These are nonprofit groups that
are already interested in literacy
and in reading and they --
often they have branches
here in Washington,
and each year we have a national
meeting for each of these affiliates
where in person we swap ideas and
promote the activities of behalf
of reading and literacy promotion.
The -- we are also the sponsors,
and I gave this major sponsor,
the Library of Congress has a
wonderful book festival each year
and the Center for the Book
plays an important role in it,
and I put this here to remind
me to tell you we have a date
for this coming book festival.
It will be here -- it will be in
the Washington Convention Center
on September the 24th, all day,
and will be having
more than 120 writers.
And the real heart of this is
the writers and the readers.
And so it's book signing and
listening to our favorite writers
and also some programming, including
of course a literacy corner.
It will be in the convention center
and that's been a wonderful way
for us to reach a broader audience.
The Center for the Book
has this program series,
which is as I mentioned, new books
by prominent writers and we --
it is a library wide series
and I know we have helped today
in recruiting the audience
and having --
helping us spread the word about
the talk from all parts of library.
And I'm pleased to see people from
the congressional research service,
which is the policy
part of the library
that deals among other
things with health,
and from the Daniel
Murray Association,
which has been supportive of Center
for the Book programs in the past.
And finally, and this is
the end of preliminary part,
by coincidence the Library
of Congress literacy awards
which were created by David
Rubenstein three years ago,
we have just finished
giving the third set
of awards, is hosting a symposium.
We do an annual symposium that kind
of stretches the boundaries
of literacy.
And last year it was
on poetry and literacy.
This year it's on literacy
and health, and it's going
to be here November --
March 16 and March 17.
And on the handout table
there is information.
It's a public event and you will
get the information and I'm hoping
that people can come on March 17.
It's really on St. Patrick's Day and
we will be talking about a subject
that is very dear to our
speaker's heart I learned
when I read his wonderful
autobiography,
which he is going to
be discussing today.
Our speaker, of course,
is Dr. Louis Sullivan,
who served as the secretary
of health,
in what did we call
it in those days?
I must have it in here,
secretary of --
health and human services
under George H. W. Bush
in the administration.
And we will hear his story today,
which is part of his
new biography --
autobiography and it's really a
moving tale, an interesting story
about how a man from Georgia
really went to Morehouse College,
attended medical school, and came
to be the secretary of health
and human services and
much more than that,
and he will be telling
you that story.
I would like to say a
word about our schedule.
All of our talks are filmed for
the Library of Congress website
and we will include a
question and answer period
as well as a book signing.
And if you are able to think of some
questions you are most welcome to.
Everything; however, will be filmed
and eventually presented
on our website.
So thank you in advance for your
permission to use your image
and I'm sure penetrating questions.
I would like to say just
another word about the program
of the Library of Congress.
We have another connection with Dr.
Sullivan that we talked about --
which I read about in this book,
and that was with Laura Bush, who --
excuse me, with Barbara Bush.
We are -- our program is
connected with both the Bushes,
who were considered
[inaudible] literacy.
His was with Barbara Bush
and he will tell a little bit
about his connection with
Barbara Bush and her concern
with adult literacy, and lo
and behold things come around,
the Barbara Bush Family
Literacy Foundation is a partner
of the Center for the Book
as part of that network
that I described earlier.
So I'm pleased to have that
connection with our guest.
Let's give him a round of
applause, Dr. Lewis Sullivan.
[ Applause ]
>> Louis W. Sullivan: Thank you.
Well thank you very much for
that generous introduction.
And I'll begin by saying for
me this is a great pleasure
and on an opportunity to be
here at Library of Congress
as part the Center
for the Book program.
So I don't forget it, let me
mention three recognitions
that the book has received; one
from Georgia Center for the Book,
that the Georgia Center for the Book
recognized my autobiography as one
of 10 books in the year 2015
that all Georgians should read.
So I was very honored,
very pleased with that.
I wasn't sure how they could
enforce that recommendation
but hopefully people
will be swayed by that.
I was also pleased to receive the
NAACP Image Award in February --
a year ago for outstanding
autobiography.
And finally, the book was a finalist
for the Phyllis Wheatley Book Award
at the Schomberg Library
in New York.
So I'm pleased with the recognition
that the book has received.
Let me also jump ahead to
tell you how the connection
with Barbara Bush occurred.
In July of 1982, at the
Morehouse School of Medicine,
we dedicated the first
structure we had developed
for the medical school.
We had Vice President George
H. W. Bush as our speaker.
And we had a great time that night.
That was his introduction to the
Morehouse School of Medicine.
This is a new school
having been formed in 1975.
And we were warned by his
staff that he could stay
after his speech only
about 15 minutes.
This is a program scheduled
for nine in the morning
because he was scheduled to speak
at a luncheon in New Orleans.
So his staff warned us
that he would probably have
to leave immediately after his talk.
Well he came, gave his talk.
This was on an outdoor patio
in front of the building.
Across the street behind the barrier
were about 15 or 20 protesters and,
of course, as the dean of this
school I was quite embarrassed.
We had the vice president
here and they were protesting.
He came out and looked.
He said, gee, only 15 to 21,
Ronnie would have 100 [laughter].
So that was where he diffused that.
Well, rather than staying --
rather than leaving immediately
afterwards he stayed almost an hour.
His staff was tugging at
him to get him to leave.
He was obviously having a good time.
I was very pleased.
And here at the program were like
Andy Young, John Lewis, Ed McIntyre,
the African American mayor
of Augusta at that time,
and many other black
officials, all of them Democrats
where they're all pushing
to get their pictures taken
with the vice president.
So I was quite pleased with
that and vice president --
then Vice President Bush
was enjoying himself
so finally his staff succeeded
in tugging him away to
go onto New Orleans.
And, of course, I was
quietly thinking, well,
perhaps the staff gave me that story
in case he was not
well received here
so there would be a rational
reason for him to leave.
But nevertheless, he
left and as he left one
of his aides pressed something
into my hand saying the vice
president would like you have these.
And later I -- I put it in my
pocket and later I pulled it out
and it's a pair of vice
presidential cufflinks.
Up until that time I didn't know
that any such thing existed.
Two weeks later, on a Friday
afternoon, I was very busy trying
to finish some things in my office
when my secretary buzzed me saying
the vice president is on the phone.
I said what vice president?
She says, oh, you've
forgotten already [laughter].
So I said, oh.
So I picked up the telephone, it was
Vice President Bush and he proceeded
to tell me that he was planning a
trip to [inaudible] South Africa
in November of that year, this
was 1982, and he wanted me
to be part of his delegation.
So I'm listening and, of
course, quite surprised.
And I said, gee, Mr. Vice President,
this sounds very interesting.
It's a very important
trip and I'll see
if I can really arrange my
calendar, but since I'm not
in government what would my role be?
He said, Lou, well to
be honest with you,
we don't have an Andy Young
in our administration.
Because you remember how
prominent Andy Young was during the
Carter years.
And he went on to say,
and I don't think I can go
to [inaudible] South Africa
without some prominent African
Americans in my delegation.
So you would do me a
favor, but more importantly,
you would do the country a service
if you would be willing to go.
So I went.
I appreciated his honesty.
On that trip was Barbara Bush.
We visited eight countries
over a two week period.
And while Bush was meeting with
the heads of state in Zimbabwe,
in Synagogue, and Nigeria, Zaire
and other countries we visited,
Barbara was talking
adult literacy groups.
And frequently I would
tag along with her.
It was very interesting.
And these groups were almost
all female, because of the level
of literacy in the various
countries in Africa.
And she obviously was committed
to this, she was enjoying it.
The audience was also enjoying it.
And I was fascinated.
So on the plane back,
this was a Wednesday,
the day before Thanksgiving
in 1982, on the way back
to the U.S. I spoke with her.
I said, Barbara, you
know, you do a great job
with these adult literacy groups.
And you know, you and I
are in the same business,
you're in adult literacy
education, I'm in medical education,
we are new school and, you know, we
are a minority school and we need
to have someone like
you on our board.
Would you be willing to consider it?
She says, well, Lou, you know,
they really make sure before I
accept anything I have to pass it
by the White House
counsel, etcetera.
So let me talk to them and
I will get back to you.
And so I was thinking,
well gosh, what a nice,
smooth way to brush
off such a request.
Well this is Wednesday, the
day before Thanksgiving.
The following Tuesday she called.
She said, Lou, I can do it.
I said great.
So she joined our board
in January of '83.
And that's how the Bush
relationship started.
So I'll come back to this a
little in my autobiography.
Well, I was born in 1933, the
depth of depression in Atlanta.
My father was an insurance salesman
for Atlanta Life Insurance Company.
Those of you who know Atlanta know
that the Atlanta Life Insurance
Company was the backbone
of the Atlanta economic
engine for blacks in Atlanta.
That was founded in the early part
of the 20th century, around 1901
and 1902 by Alonzo Herndon, who
himself had been born a slave.
That organization grew and supported
the development of a number
of other financial organizations.
One was Mutual Federal
Savings and Loans.
Because in Atlanta back in the '30s
and '40s blacks could not get
mortgages from white banks,
but they got them from Mutual
Federal Savings and Loans.
And so growing up in Atlanta we
saw that blacks had fine homes.
There's also a real estate --
several real estate companies,
a property insurance
company, many other businesses
in the Atlanta community.
So my father was a
salesman for Atlanta Life,
but during the depression nobody
was buying life insurance.
So I was the second of two boys.
So thinking of how he would really
support his family, he left Atlanta
and moved to southwest
Georgia and founded the first
in black funeral home in Blakely,
Georgia, in southwest Georgia.
Blakely is about 58 miles west of
Albany, and about 28 miles east
of Dothan, Alabama, about 70
miles north of the Florida border.
So down in southwest Georgia.
In those years this was the
heart [inaudible] country.
In addition to founding
a funeral home,
he did a number of other things.
He founded the first
chapter of the NAACP.
He started an annual emancipation
day celebration on January 1
of every year that the African
American community was celebrating
Lincoln's emancipation.
We would have bands,
speakers, parade downtown,
voter registration
efforts, because in addition
to his other activities he was
working like many other blacks
in Georgia to have a
repeal of the white primary
where blacks could not participate.
So he was quite an activist.
And because of his
activism my mother,
who was a school teacher having
taught in North Carolina prior
to them getting married, in spite of
her experience as a school teacher,
during the 20 years they
lived there from 1937 to 1957,
my mother never got a position
as teacher in [inaudible] country
where Blakely is the county seat.
During those 20 years she had
to drive to other counties
where she taught, ranging from 14
miles to as far as 40 miles away.
My brother, Walter, who is a
year and a half older than I,
never attended school in Blakely.
We attended school where
my mother was teaching.
So we would go to Bluffton,
to Cuthbert, other places.
But by the time I was in fifth
grade, my brother in sixth grade,
we went to Savannah to live with our
aunts where my mother had grown up
and attended school there that year,
and that was because of my parents'
commitment to the two of us getting
as best an education as we could.
Because in those years segregated
schools in rural Georgia,
schools for blacks were
really not very good.
We got hand-me-down books.
When white school got
books we got the used books
from the white school.
The white school had a band,
the black school did not,
there were no instruments, etcetera.
So there were many
obvious deficiencies
in the educational
offerings for blacks
in rural Georgia in those years.
The following when I was in sixth
grade my mother returned to Atlanta
to study for her master's in
education and my brother and I went
with her and we lived in
Atlanta during that year.
By the end of that year she had
arranged for a friend to take us
in as borders during
the school year.
So from sixth grade on my brother
and I attended school in Atlanta.
We would go home to
Blakely on the summer
or Christmas or other holidays.
Well, there are many scenes that we
describe in the book from Blakeley.
One of them out was when the local
policeman was going by our house
and I was on the front porch
with our dog and he had a BB gun,
he was shooting stray dogs
and he thought this was
the funniest thing ever.
So he shot my dog.
I was about age 11.
And when that happened I was
quite surprised and I was angry.
I ran down to the curb and
asked, why did you shoot my dog?
So he pointed the gun
at me and said, well,
would you like to have some?
So I said, you wait here.
And I was so angry, I was
crying, tears run down,
ran in the house looking
in the chifforobe drawer
where my father kept his gun.
Fortunately, it was not
there because he was away
and he always carried
his gun with him.
My mother, who was in the back
of the house, heard the noise
when the door slammed,
came up and found me crying
in their bedroom looking
for my dad's gun.
So she grabbed me to find
out what was going on.
And also at time the
iceman was there
because what we had was a
refrigerator where we had
to purchase ice every day.
So the iceman came up and the two
of them restrained me while
they learned what was going on.
So about 20 minutes later my father
returned with my brother to find
out -- to return home
and found this commotion.
And he stood quietly as I
told him what had happened.
So without saying anything more he
told my brother, Walter, he said,
Walter, you come with me.
So Walter said, where are we going?
They got in the car, he says we're
going down to the sheriff's office.
So we went down.
And in those years one of the
things that happened in Blakely,
as all over the south, blacks were
never addressed as Mr. or Mrs.,
it was Annie or Bill or
Joe or what have you.
So my father went into the
police station in the front.
And the policeman was in the back.
So my father yelled out
in a loud voice, Dallas,
his last name was Dallas.
Dallas? So he peered out.
Oh, yes, [inaudible] and he
says what can I do for you?
He said, well, I understand
that there was some
trouble up at my house.
He says, trouble, what
kind of trouble?
I understand that there
was a problem with my dog.
Oh, I don't what.
So my father then pulled
this revolver out of his belt
and put it right between his eyes.
He said look, let me
tell you something,
he said if you ever have
any trouble with my wife
or my boys you don't say
or do anything to them.
You come to me.
Because if anything
like this happens again,
I will blow your brains out.
By this time Dallas was really
melting with perspiration.
So from then -- those years on we
never had any trouble in Blakely.
But my father, I'm sure as you
know, was known within some
of the white community
as that crazy N,
you know the N word they always use.
Well, we -- my father retired in
1957 and that's when they moved
to Fort Lauderdale, Florida where
my mother got a position teaching
school in Fort Lauderdale.
My experience with the schools
in Atlanta was very different.
While the community was segregated,
there's a strong black community
in Atlanta, I mentioned the business
community, but there's also a group
of black colleges in Atlanta
that many of you have heard of,
Morehouse College being one,
Spelman College being another.
Morehouse is all male,
Spelman all female.
Clark College, which
is co-educational
and my mother had graduated from
Clark College and my brother,
a year ahead of me, also
went to Clark College.
The presence of those colleges mean
that over the years
there are a number
of well-educated African
Americans in Atlanta,
and that has fed the growth of
a professional class in Atlanta,
not only in business but in the
arts, etcetera, and it's no accident
that the civil rights leaders
really focused in Atlanta.
So Atlanta, over the years, even
in those years back in the '40s,
was really different
from the rest of Georgia
for the African American community.
[inaudible] that has been the
white leadership in Atlanta led
by Bob Woodruff, the
former CEO of Coca-Cola.
Because when I graduated from Booker
Washington High in Atlanta in 1950,
there were about 400
in my graduating class.
There were a number of students
who received scholarships
from an anonymous donor.
And every time that anonymous
donor scholarship was announced
when a student was
introduced, there's a murmur --
a knowing murmur that
went through the room,
because we knew this
was Bob Woodruff
and the Woodruff Foundation.
So Bob Woodruff set
the tone for business
and business leaders in Atlanta.
Some -- to jump ahead
to mention a few things,
to show what I mean is this.
When Martin Luther King Junior
was assassinated it turned
out by coincidence Bob Woodruff
was in the Oval Office meeting
with President Lyndon Johnson.
The President's aide came in with a
message for Mr. Woodruff for a call
and that's when he learned
about King's assassination.
So he then -- Woodruff then called
Chief Inman, the chief of police
in Atlanta and told him, well,
we don't want to have any riots
in the home of Martin Luther King
Junior, so whatever you need,
if you don't have it in your
budget, I'm good for it.
So that was one example.
Another was earlier in the '60s
when Martin Luther King Junior
received the Nobel Prize.
They planned a dinner
in his honor in Atlanta.
And it turns out about a week
before the dinner there were few --
only a few of the white
business leaders
who had signed up for the dinner.
Bob Woodruff sent out a
message saying Coca-Cola is an
international company.
We happen to be based in Atlanta,
but we don't have to based
in Atlanta if we cannot honor a
son who has gotten the Nobel Prize.
The dinner was sold out
before sundown on that day.
So Atlanta has been
blessed by others
who have really taken the spirit
of Woodruff so that the level
of communication and cooperation
between black leadership in Atlanta
and white leadership in
Atlanta has been great.
Let me give you one further example.
You've seen around the country
the failure of public hospitals
because of lack of support in them.
D.C. General has experienced
that because D.C. General
Hospital closed.
A number of other hospitals,
Philadelphia General Hospital
closed, St. Louis Hospital closed,
and in Los Angeles the Martin
Luther King Junior Hospital closed,
because public hospitals have a
difficult time with the number
of patients who -- that they
serve who have high costs
but there's no insurance and they
don't have the funds themselves
and they depend upon support
from their local governments.
And if that support is not
enough the hospitals fail.
Grady Hospital in 2008
was in such a position.
But the Chamber of Commerce met
with Fulton County Commissioners
and they came up with the idea
of privatizing the governance
of the hospital so that the
personnel issues would be private,
the hiring, evaluation,
firing of the CEO, contracts,
etcetera would be approved
by this non-profit board,
which would operate the
hospital by contract.
I served on the Grady
board at that time
until a year ago, March
of last year.
So with that participation by the
business leadership in Atlanta,
Grady Hospital has been rescued.
It went from a $50 million
annual deficit to less
than $10 million annual
deficit today,
and had the county
continued the level of support
that they were giving in 2008 Grady
would be actually well in the black.
So there's that kind of community
in Atlanta that my brother, Walter,
and I grew up in, so
we have enjoyed that.
In high school, at
Booker Washington High,
our teachers were very
dedicated, they were inspiring.
They did everything to try
and interest us in learning
and challenging us to do well.
So I went on Morehouse College.
Surprised my family described
that episode in the book
when I told parents that I
wanted to go to Morehouse.
My father's reaction said, you
know, no, we are a Methodist family,
that's a Baptist school [laughter].
So I said, dad, you know,
they started out affiliated
with the Baptist but they've
been independent a long time.
He said, well, he kept going --
said, well, dad, I'm not going
to church, I'm going to college.
So my mother intervened and
said, Walt, if he wants to go
to Morehouse, Morehouse is a good
school, so let's let him do that.
So I went on to Morehouse.
My friends were going to Morehouse
from my high school class.
I wanted to go places they went.
At Morehouse I came
under the influence
of Dr. Benjamin Elijah Mays.
Dr. Mays served as the president of
this college from 1940 until 1967.
He came in towards the
end of the depression.
The college, like so many
colleges around the country,
was struggling with its finances.
But through his diligence, he was an
eloquent speaker, he was a preacher,
well-known, spoke all
over the country,
the National Council of Churches.
He would speak for example
at [inaudible] State College
for their Easter service
every year, etcetera.
So Dr. Mays really
rescued Morehouse.
He recruited a strong faculty.
So when I entered in 1950 I
was really entering a place
where there were many scholars
and he was always challenging
the students to do well.
One of his sayings
that he would say,
and he spoke every
Tuesday at chapel.
Now in those years as a
student, chapel was compulsory
at Morehouse, and we
didn't like that.
We said we're supposed to be adults,
why are we being treated
like children?
We're being compelled to do this.
Because if we didn't
attend we would get demerits
and it would actually take
away from our college credits.
And it happens that one very good
friend of mine, who did well,
had earned all the credits
he needed to graduate,
but he had so many demerits
he did not graduate.
He had to attend summer
school to make up the credits.
So that was it.
So we really on the one hand,
we resented that because we felt
that we were supposed
to be treated as adults,
but you're treating
us like children.
Well, I can tell you as an alumnus
looking back I'm glad we had
to attend chapel.
Because not only did
we hear Dr. Mays,
but we heard many other
outstanding speakers,
Thurgood Marshall would come
leading the legal defense fund
in the [inaudible]
legal defense fund.
We had many local speakers.
Attorney Walden, who
was one of the leaders
in the black community
really negotiating
with then Mayor Hartsfield.
He led an effort, but they would
sit down with Mayor Hartsfield
and say we want our roads paved,
we want these schools [inaudible],
we want a swimming
pool here, etcetera.
And so with Mayor Hartsfield
agreeing to that,
the blacks would vote for him.
And so he remained as mayor
for a number of years.
And as you know, the Atlanta Airport
became the Hartsfield Airport.
It's now the Jackson
Hartsfield Airport
with Maynard Jackson's
name after it.
So at Morehouse we were really
taught to work to excel.
And he would -- Dr. Mays would say
such things to us as this, he said,
whatever you choose to do in
life, you should do it so well
that no man living, no man dead, and
no men yet to be could do it better.
He said, if you commit yourself
to that, when they're looking
for someone in your field they
will have to consider you.
You may not get the job,
but it should not be
because you're not prepared.
Because he was telling us,
we're in a segregated world
and we may really not get
the job but he said this,
nothing more unfortunate than having
an opportunity presented to you
and you're not prepared, you're
not ready to take advantage of it.
And as you know, Martin Luther King
Junior is our most famous graduate
of Morehouse College,
having finished in 1948.
He came under Dr. Mays' spell.
And Dr. Mays gave his eulogy
when Martin Luther King died.
So that was the environment that
I was privileged to be a part
of during my college years.
And I then went on to medical
school at Boston University.
So first Morehouse graduate
to go to Boston University,
and in those years there
very few blacks going
to predominantly white schools.
[inaudible] were the schools
that were educating the most
of the nation's black
physicians, and they continue
to educate a significant
number today.
So in September of 1954, shortly
after the Supreme Court's Brown
versus Board of Education decision
that declared separate schools were
inherently unequal and; therefore,
unconstitutional, that was year I
entered Boston University School
of Medicine.
For me this was several
significant things.
First, of course, I was
going to medical school,
which I was very excited about
because I had been really mesmerized
by one black physician
in southwest Georgia,
Dr. Joseph Griffin [assumed
spelling], who was in Bainbridge.
Bainbridge was 41 miles
south of Blakely.
When my parents needed about a
doctor they didn't go to the doctors
in Blakely because with the white
doctors there were segregated
waiting rooms.
Usually the black waiting room was
around the side or around the back.
So they didn't like that.
So they would not go.
Only in an emergency would
they use the white physicians.
And my father operated an ambulance
service and many other blacks
who could afford it would use my
father's ambulance service to go
down to Bainbridge
to see Dr. Griffin.
Dr. Griffin, when you would open the
door of his clinic, it was a 25 bed,
brick clinic, unusual
brick structure.
He was obviously very
successful, highly respected.
Open the door, there would
be the smell of ether,
which is kind of a
sweet, pungent smell,
and he would be wearing scrub suits.
And so for me as a young
boy I found him fascinating.
I was interested in science
and trees and birds and flowers
and wild animals and so forth.
So for me biology was a natural.
But Dr. Griffin was special
because he could cure people,
to take care of people who were ill.
So from age five I decided
I wanted to be a doctor.
So that was my goal as I went
through high school and then went
through college and then went
on to Boston University there,
not quite 21 years of age.
My first time living in a
non-segregated environment.
I wondered, how am I
going to be received here?
Will it be with hostility?
Will it be ignored or indifferent?
Or will it be welcomed?
Well, to make a long story short,
I had a great experience
at Boston University.
My classmates and my
faculty well received me.
I was the only black in
my class of 76 students.
Another thing was interesting
at Boston University, they --
a class of 76 students, we had
seven women and we were boasting
at that time that only the
medical college for Women
in Pennsylvania had more
women medical students.
And, of course, that's very
different today because about half
of the nation's medical
students are female.
So when I entered Boston University
in 1954, this was really a time
for me of new beginnings, living
in a non-segregated environment,
really studying medicine, which
had been my lifelong goal,
and also the center where
the revolution started,
where there was a Boston tea party.
The Paul Revere ride,
the battle at Lexington,
and the bridge in Concord.
And I walked the freedom trail
and took in that history,
Colonial [inaudible] regiment,
the all-black regiment
from the Civil War [inaudible] just
opposite the capital building there
in Boston.
And so this for me was
a tremendous experience.
I worried when entered.
Here my classmates, these guys
who finished Amherst, Williams,
Princeton, Harvard,
Columbia, etcetera,
places I had really heard
about all these years.
Of course, during our first week
we would be meeting each other
and say hi Lou, I'm
from, you know, Holyoke,
Massachusetts and I went to Amherst.
Where did you go?
I said, I went to Mores.
Oh yeah, Morehead, great school.
No, no, no, not Morehead,
North Carolina, Morehouse.
Oh, Morehouse, where's that?
So my classmates hardly
knew about it.
So here I am.
The one black in my class.
I'm wondering, am I
going to do okay?
Will I let my parents down?
Will I let Dr. Mays
or Morehouse down?
Since I was the only black I'm kind
of really representing
the black community.
Will I embarrass myself?
All these guys who finished
at the top of their class
at all these places and they
never heard of where I came from.
Well, our first examine in anatomy
was about three weeks later.
I got a great score so I
relaxed and I enjoyed my --
the rest of my medical school years.
I served as class president
for two of my four years there.
So I had a great experience.
Then when I graduated I went
through a similar phenomenon
because I was accepted
for an internship
at Cornell Medical Center.
1958 New York Hospital had
never had a black intern.
So I went there.
The chief of medicine had
come up from Tennessee.
When he interviewed me I
said oh-oh, this is it.
And I'm saying they're just doing
this to say they interviewed.
But sure enough I was surprised.
I was accepted there, spent two
years, had a great experience there,
and his name was Hugh
Lucky [assumed spelling].
To fast forward, in 1975
when I went back to Morehouse
to start the medical school one of
the first grants we received was
from the Josiah Macy Foundation
where Hugh Lucky was one
of the board of directors.
So he and I got to be great friends.
And so that experience
taught me a lesson,
because I had automatically assumed
with his thick, southern drawl
when he interviewed me that I
was out, but turned out to --
became one of my best
friends and boosters.
So that showed me I had my own
prejudices I had to work to address.
Went back to Boston for training in
hematology, first at Mass General
for a year and then at
the Thornback Laboratory
at Harvard at Boston City Hospital.
Then joined the faculty first in
New Jersey College of Medicine,
but then recruited back to Boston
after two years to
my medical school.
I wanted to become what eventually
was a professor of medicine.
I thought I was really then set
on my life's path because I wanted
to be chairman of the department of
the medicine hopefully by age 45,
but at age 41 Morehouse
College decided they wanted
to start a medical school, and I
worked with them as an advisor.
I was very pleased to advise them
on this, but then they surprised me
by asking if I would come
back to head up the school.
And after some thought,
and I describe this
in the book with details.
My wife, Ginger, I got
married in medical school.
She's from Massachusetts, three
children born in Massachusetts.
So my ties to Georgia had
become a little tenuous.
But the idea of medical school
at Morehouse was fascinating
because the rationale for
the school is as follows.
A shortage of black physicians and
other black health professionals.
In 1950 2% of the nation's
physicians were African American
when blacks were at
10% of the population.
During the civil rights era a lot
of things changed, including efforts
to increase the number
of African American,
and other minority
health professionals.
So today rather than
2% it's about 4.7%.
Whereas blacks now are 12% of
the population, Hispanics are 15%
of the population, and
they represent only about 4
or 5% of the nation's physicians.
So the rationale for
developing a more --
a school medicine at Morehouse
was to increase the number
of African American and
other minority physicians.
And so I went back and worked there,
established the medical school
which became independent from the
college in 1981, and we started
as a two year school but evolved
into a four year school there.
And I can say to you today
that we now have a number
of graduates who have done well.
We've produced a surgeon general,
Regina Benjamin was
one of our graduates.
We produced the president
of another medical school.
And one of our graduates from South
Africa returned to South African
and developed the first
nationwide blood banking system
in South Africa, modeled after the
Red Cross blood banking system.
I was there in October of
2010, had dinner with him.
They were celebrating the completion
of their first year of operation
without a single case
of transmission of HIV
or hepatitis C virus, so it's a
very important contribution there.
So those are the things that
have animated me during my life.
I'm officially retired but
I'm still active in a number
of voluntary organizations working
to not only improve the health
system, because my focus is not only
on the African American and
other minority communities,
but on our country at large.
Because during my time
as secretary we worked
to develop a new food
label, which was approved.
We worked to discourage tobacco use
and to improve healthy behavior,
because I say that while the
20th century was a century
in which we experienced tremendous
advances in the sciences,
[inaudible] medicine with
many new drugs, new therapies,
medical devices, life
expectancy has improved
because of improvements
in public health.
The 21st century is going to
have its major improvements
if we could improve the health
behavior of our citizens.
That's why I was pleased to launch
Healthy People 2000 in September
of 1990 when I was secretary.
That has continued now and
so with increased emphasis
on healthy behavior we hope to see
many improvements in the health
of our citizens going forward.
So with that I will stop and will be
pleased to respond to any questions
or comments that you might have
either on things I have mentioned
or things I may not have mentioned,
I will be happy to
try and respond to.
So thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
Yes?
[ Inaudible Comment ]
Yes.
Yes. Well, first of all, let
me say the question was what
about my experience at HHS?
What are some of the
memories I take from that?
I would say this.
The first, I was impressed with
the dedication and the expertise
of the employees at HHS,
because I had not been
in public service before.
Of course, what I had heard from
various members of congress,
who were always criticizing things
about the federal bureaucrats
suggesting
that that person is really
either incompetent or inefficient
or whatever, I'm sure there's
some of that, but there's some
of that in the private sector.
But I was impressed by the number of
employees who were not only expert
in their fields but who worked hard.
Occasionally I would sneak in to
my office on a Saturday or Sunday
to try and do some things
quietly because of my schedule.
But I noticed in the parking
lot under the building about 20%
of the places have cars
there, employees were there.
When I would have briefings
on various activities,
because I was impressed by that.
So that was the first thing.
The second thing that
I was impressed by,
in somewhat of a different way,
was how personal the programs
of HHS are to so many people.
Because HHS deals with so called hot
button issues, abortion, abortion,
animal rights, because many
animal groups don't like --
don't approve of animal
experimentation,
so they really do everything
to try and stop that.
Because I'm a supporter I'm
certainly for ethical treatment
of animals, but there's so many
advances that have occurred
because of our ability to work --
to do work on animals
so that when we work
on humans we're not --
we are at less risk.
Another group that was a
surprise was the disability group.
I would go to speak at a
commencement or what have you,
people would be wheeled --
brought in wheelchairs and so
the ushers would bring them right
down front so they could be seen,
and they would be there
very orderly, etcetera.
Then when I would get up to
speak they would throw themselves
out of their wheelchairs and start
crawling towards the station --
towards the podium chatting,
why won't you meet with us?
Well, their issue was this.
They wanted to have 1/3
of the have funds spent
for nursing homes spent
for home care.
And, of course, my
staff had met with them
and explained, well,
it's in the law.
The secretary does not have the
authority to change the law.
It has to be changed
by the congress.
But nevertheless, they
would be there.
And, of course, in front
of an audience, you know,
you couldn't explain that.
If it, as you know, this thing is
if it takes you more than a sentence
to explain it you've lost it.
So that was really something
which was very unusual.
So when I was sworn in by my
assistant secretary for personnel,
because the day I was
confirmed by the senate he came
up with this Bible and swore me in.
I said, wait a minute, we're
going to have an assembly.
He says, oh yes, we'll have that
in a couple weeks, you know,
but the real ceremony
is swearing you
in right now before they
change their mind [laughter].
So I took the oath.
But when he swore me in
he said, congratulations,
you are now the most sued person
on the universe [laughter].
That would -- most of that
was social security issues.
People had legal issues
about eligibility or payment
or other things like that.
So those are things -- some of
the things that surprised me,
and of course I also learned you
don't have to explain or qualify
or apologize for words
that you didn't say.
In other words, during
my orientation one
of the things I was always
taught, think through now
when you have a question,
particularly in an
emotional setting.
Don't just strike out, because
then you might say the wrong thing
and then you're forever
trying to say,
well what the secretary
really was trying to say,
or meant to say, etcetera.
So that was another thing.
Because I learned, of course, that
the press is out there to make news,
and you may be their
vehicle to make news.
So if they can get you to say
something that is different
or sounds different,
etcetera, that's a problem.
So those are some of
the things there.
But overall I say my experience
for me was 90% positive,
only about 10% negative, because
I got used to being picketed
after a time and I
realized that really it's
because I have this position.
Once I was no longer secretary on
January 20, 1993, the pickets went
to the new secretary,
so they didn't go to me.
Yes?
[ Inaudible Comment ]
The Zika virus?
Yes, right.
Well, let me just repeat
the question.
What is the status of understandable
about the Zika virus, if I --
[ Inaudible Comment ]
Yes, and the way we stop it, yes.
Well first of all, the Zika virus
has been around for a long time,
but it's been really primarily
in Africa or in South America.
And so there you have a population
that has been exposed to that virus
so there's a lot of immunity there.
But what has happened in Brazil,
this virus has come in to areas
where it was not there before.
So you have a population that is --
what's called naive in
terms of immunologic terms,
they have not had the virus before.
So indeed when people are
infected with it, of course,
first of all it's my understanding
that in most instances it's a very
mild viral infection, maybe a rash,
etcetera, but in a few instances
you might have these severe
complications that are being seen.
So that's one of the issues.
I do know that there is a
lot of work being done to try
and develop a vaccine for the virus.
There's other work that's being
done by experts in insects to try
and develop -- to change the
genome of the mosquito so that
if they -- the goal is this.
If they can change that so that the
mosquito cannot carry the virus,
then that will stop the epidemic.
Then thirdly, environmental things
such as getting rid of pools
of water where the mosquito
multiplies, etcetera.
So there are a lot of
things that are being done.
And, of course, they're working to
hopefully develop perhaps some kind
of antiviral against
the virus itself.
So all of these things
are being done,
but because this is really
relevant -- coming into new areas,
including the possibility
of a southern U.S.
because of climate change
that is with global warming.
That means that the mosquito
could move into areas
where it was not there before
because of the warmer environment.
So, of course, for reference
towards combating global warming,
this is another argument
to really do better on that
because the Zika is only one
of a number of conditions
that really could become present
that are not present
in our current climate.
And, of course, we had the
Ebola virus a few years ago.
And, of course, this is another
example of a virus that has been
in an area but now is coming
into new areas that we have
to find ways to combat that.
Yes, yes?
[ Inaudible Comment ]
Good morning.
Okay, I hope I got the second part
of your question correct
and, if not, just tell me.
So the question you're asking
is what things can be done --
well, is our health system
undergoing a revolution or changes?
And I would say yes, but it's
a question of definition.
The fact is throughout the
course of 20th century starting
with Teddy Roosevelt, there has been
an expressed desire of leadership
to have a universal
healthcare system.
Now the argument has been, what
would be the shape of that?
The -- because our current
system is a mixture of public
and private participation, Medicare
and Medicaid being the
largest public systems,
but also the Veterans'
Administration,
Department of Defense,
and other parts
of the publicly provided healthcare.
The, of course, the private
being through insurance
or through employer
provided healthcare,
so we have this combined
public provide mix.
Our healthcare system really,
I think, has made a number
of remarkable contributions to
life in America to improve life.
Life expectancy in 1900 for an
infant born that year was 47 years.
Today it is approaching 80 years.
That's primarily due to
improvements in public health
such as safe drinking water,
the elimination of malaria
from the southern part of
the country that was present
in the early part of the 20th
century, safe drinking water.
And then the development of first
of all sulfa drugs back in the '20s
and '30s and then antibiotics
and many other things.
And medical devices, such as cardiac
pacemakers, artificial joints.
I have an artificial hip that before
artificial joints were available,
and they were not available
when I was a medical student,
people would be immobilized if
they developed arthritis, etcetera.
So we've had throughout the course
of the 20th century remarkable
advances in medical care
and in health -- more American
scientists throughout the course
of the 20th century have received
Nobel Prizes in physiology
and medicine than in the
rest of the world combined.
So that's a measure of the strength
of the science in our country.
So those are the things that we are
proud of, but we also have a system
that has a number of
problems or challenges.
First of all, it's too expensive.
Everyone agrees on that.
Health consumes about 6% of
gross domestic product in 1965
when Medicare and Medicaid
were instituted.
In 1989 when I came to
Washington as secretary of health
and human services, it was
11%, it almost doubled.
We were spending $1 trillion
for healthcare from public
and private sources in 1989.
In 2010 it was $2.4
trillion, it more than doubled
since I had come to Washington.
And it was taking 18% of
gross domestic product.
So the path we are on really is
not sustainable because that means
that health will squeeze out
education, transportation, housing,
other things if we don't change it.
So in that sense we have
to -- have to address it.
But the question you
raised is very complex.
We have a lot to be proud of,
but we also have a lot to address
and not everyone is covered
and that's what the Affordable
Care Act is designed to do.
That's made some improvements.
And for the record, I'm for that.
I really wish that members of
congress would see the obligation is
to serve the people rather
than to fight each other,
which has been the case
for the last several years.
So overall we've made
improvements but we have a lot
yet to do if this is to continue.
>> John Cole: You have time for two
more quick questions if we could.
[ Inaudible Comment ]
Yes, well, thank you for that.
That in 25 words or less, right.
I think the question was,
what about health disparities,
what is the situation with the
African American community,
particularly African American males?
And I would say this,
there's a lot to that.
I would summarize it by saying
the health of Americans,
of all Americans, improved
tremendously throughout the
20th century.
Black Americans today
are living longer
than white Americans
were living in 1900.
So everyone has improved.
The gap in life expectancy
between blacks and whites back
in 1900 was about 15 to 17 years.
The gap -- there's still a gap but
now it's around six to seven years.
So the gap has narrowed
but it's still there.
We still -- we have a --
we are undergoing a tremendous shift
democratically in our population.
35% of Americans today
are either Latino,
African American, or
Native American.
Roughly 10% of our
health professionals come
from these groups.
And among some it's even lower, I
think around -- dentists around 6%.
So we have to do better.
And the reason for that
is that the relationship
between the health professional
and the patient also
affects the outcome.
So we have many instances where
there is a very good relationship
between the health professional
who may be of a different racial
or ethnic group, but
often there is some bias,
even unconscious bias there.
And that's one of the reasons
for more diversity among the
nation's health professions.
Now the final comment is this, that
we really are in serious trouble
with the health profession so
far as African American males.
You probably are referring to the
study that just came out last August
that showed that in the year
2014 there was something
like 525 African American
males entering medical school,
but that was actually 25 fewer
African American males entering
medical school than
occurred in 1978.
1978 happens to be the year that
we [inaudible] class students
at Morehouse School of Medicine.
So whereas other groups
have made progress,
there are more Hispanics going,
and actually let me say this,
there are more African Americans
going to medical school today
but it's because we have more
African American females,
2/3 of African American medical
students today are female.
Because there are around 1,400
African American first year medical
students around the
country now, and about nine,
eight or 900 of those are
female, the rest are male.
So we need to do things
to address that.
And the Sullivan Alliance
is an organization
that I had -- was formed in 2005.
We we're working in nine
states with programs
to increase the success
rate of minority youngsters
in gaining access to
health professions career,
not only medicine but
dentistry, nursing, other fields,
and fields such as
physician's assistants,
nurse practitioners, etcetera.
So there's a lot to do.
And so we are far from
having an ideal system,
but we're still plugging and hoping
that over the next few
decades we will get there.
>> John Cole: One last question.
Ma'am?
[ Inaudible Comment ]
Yes, right.
Sure, right.
Well, the question I'll
repeat is, you retired in '95
from you said HEW, but
it was HEW up until 1976.
That means you started before
1976 since you used HEW
because it's Health and Human
Services since the mid '70s
when education was split off.
By the way, Lamar Alexander, when
he became secretary of education,
I had over for lunch in
my private dining room.
And the first thing I said, Lamar, I
want the rest of my department back,
because Carter split off
education because of his agreement
with the teachers union, but that
really shouldn't have happened.
But anyway, that's when
it changed [laughter].
Now your question, first of all,
most generics are just as good.
There's hardly any problem.
But physician, if he insists that
you should have a brand name,
can write that, say no
generic substitution,
but you would have to pay that.
You can't get the brand name
drug at the generic price.
So -- but I think the rare
situation if you have a generic
that was not really as
good as a brand name.
What -- it's similar to, you know,
why do we pay the Mercedes
price for a Mercedes car?
Well, that's -- a part of
that is the image, etcetera.
Well in the pharmaceutical
industry maybe [inaudible]
but really generics are quite good.
I take a number of
medications and they're generics
and I'm perfectly happy with it.
>> John Cole: On that positive note,
joint me [applause] in applause for.
Thank you so much.
I want to thank Dr. Sullivan for not
only giving this wonderful picture
of his life, his inspirational
story, but also handing
out some practical medical advice.
It shows that he is on top of this
field, he's on top of several fields
and I remain very impressed with
him and thank him for his being here
and his patience and for the
books that you are about to sign.
You will have a chance to
continue the conversation
when we have a book signing here.
The books are on sale for the
Library of Congress 10% discount.
I am very proud of the Georgia
Center for the Book for saying
that on their list,
on their website,
that every Georgian
should read this book.
I agree and I wish I had thought of
that line to start my introduction.
One final round of
applause and meet him
over for the book signing
[applause].
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us @loc.gov.